the first thing he says to them is oh I
was just looking you guys up on the
Internet John Travolta majorly mortified
his daughter in front of her celebrity
crush the actor stopped by Jimmy Kimmel
Live with his 19 year old daughter Ella
blue to promote their new flick the
poison rose and Ella opened up about the
embarrassing moment she had with Taylor
Lautner courtesy of her famous dad
Taylor Lautner was coming over to the
house pictures of him and just of course
and then Taylor gets there and won and
his family as well so I was researching
about them to write just to let you know
cuz research yeah yeah so and the first
thing he says to them is oh I was just
looking you guys up on the Internet
brutal right well John defended himself
to the show's guest host Lena wait
a father's part of used you know
everybody loves Taylor Lautner wouldn't
wouldn't he be flattered and despite her
embarrassment
Taylor laughed off the exchange she's
like oh my face like bright red probably
during his stop by the late-night show
John also dished on his new balls due
and admitted he was shocked by how fast
his look went viral viral before that
was mispronounced idina menzel and while
some fans aren't a fan of his shaved
down appearance John says he likes it
and so does his pal pitbull I became
friends with pitbull and I loved him and
he encouraged it as well and the family
encouraged when et caught up with John
in February he joked that pitbull was
one of his inspirations for the new
haircut I love the haircut and I first
of all I think it was the move is it
true the pitbull inspired you
Way is one of my inspirations you're
sure I mean I did this had just look for
a movie called
from Paris with love years ago but you
know I never thought of wearing it as
like a full-time look and then my family
said what are you shave it for the new
year and then I dared to put post-it on
my Instagram
it went crazy went viral right it was
much more than I ever expected and it
went headlines so I felt like Zoolander
or something didn't and I'm going for it
[Music]